joe biden was talking about the uh
voting laws
and he says what we're seeing is the
greatest threat since the civil war
the insurrectionists reached the capitol
the confederates never did that
and you know we've talked about this a
bit in the past several episodes but i
want to add something to this idea
joe biden's only saying these things
that
paint half the country as enemies of the
state
because he's confident that in the
coming years
this group of people will be will be
figuratively eradicated
what i mean by that is politically
eradicated that they're fractured
they can't organize they won't win
elections and their opinions are
completely meaningless and then it's
going to be the
overstate or the cathedral that controls
everything and you look at what's
happened with the police
and i think actually interestingly the
resistance of conservatives
is what helped convert police
departments into woke enforcement
agencies
when the left started saying abolish the
police and defund the police
and put extreme pressure on the police
departments
conservatives stop the departments from
completely going under by pushing back
and then you had this argument over
whether or not we really want to abolish
police and it worked out really really
well for the woke
because then the good cops were like i'm
not going to be a part of this
leave who's left the people who either
don't care or willing to do whatever
they're told
and then because conservatives save the
department from being totally abolished
they were able to restock it up with
cops who know exactly
what these uh modern political times
will bear
so now i would only i would only uh
speculate
you know we're moving into 2022 we're
going to have the midterms
they're going to be coming after
conservatives like you cannot even
believe
they they have already been tweeting
things like if we lose the house it's
all
over yes their glorious revolution will
be all over
if republicans get back the house and
can impeach joe biden for high crimes
and misdemeanors
so what do you think they'll do they're
going to come after right-wing
influencers
they're going to come after
anti-establishment in any capacity which
includes some anti-war leftist types and
people like jimmy dore for instance i
don't know if they'll ban him
but they've gone after people in this
area who are anti-war
anti-anti-establishment democrat
they're going to try and get rid of
anybody who might actually make them
look bad
and they'll do it very slowly if they do
it overnight it'll cause too much of an
uproar
but they can't they can't they can't
afford to lose the house yeah i think
you're seeing this with glenn greenwald
right he's kind of become a uh
a bad lefty because he has joined sides
with the populist right and talking
about how terrible the national security
apparatus is
but but he's he's always been that right
the populist right finally joined him
that's right that's a good point
um but here is something to consider is
that i'm not sure that even if
republicans would resume
like assume power again
it's not clear that it would actually
make a difference because it seems to be
the case that
republicans can win elections but
the left will remain in control of
institutions
right and and therefore elections are
kind of just
they're like respites there there are
periods where we can catch our breath
maybe plan pressure release yeah that's
all it is
but ultimately the trajectory of the
country does not
change if we follow the same trajectory
as we did in the in trump's first term
that is to say in 2022 republicans win
but then the democrats wield the power
of the
of the intelligence agencies against
conservatives and
and jams them up investigates and
crushes them
republicans are are at a loss
republicans don't do this republicans
don't fight back
and then we move into 2023 with the
presidency same thing
one of my favorite memes right now is
this idea you hear a lot of libertarians
are saying things like this they're like
the democrats think the republicans are
lying cheating and stealing and
manipulating to gain more power
and the republicans think the democrats
are lying cheating and stealing to gain
more power
people need to realize you know both
sides that is not true
republicans don't do anything
republicans have no cultural
institutions they don't have
universities they don't have movies
they got nothing the best conservatives
can muster is ben shapiro putting out a
movie
and that's great you know respect for
putting on this pronounced movie and
getting entertainment
so they're actually doing something but
conservatives
are not reaching children they're not
reaching young people you know
there was a tweet i i think um i can
remember where i saw this
maybe from cassandra fairbanks that
nickelodeon or disney channel was
playing anti-trump ads
oh yeah she was talking about that was
that cassandra yeah anti-donald trump
ads on disney channel why
those kids will grow up in 10 years from
now
those 10 year olds will be 20 and they
are going to be ideological extremists
and they'll vote and you won't even
realize it some of these kids right now
15
15 years old three more years and
they're voting and you you got to figure
out what these kids are thinking and i'm
sure the democrats are doing exactly
that and that's why schools are
indoctrinating them
because what's going to happen is you
are going to get some classically
liberal
leftist i mean it actual like lefty
individual
who well i shouldn't say classically
liberal we'll say traditional liberal
agrees a lot of conservatives someone
similar to maybe like me they'll run for
office
but in in three to five years they'll be
considered far right
like like uh we had vosh on the show and
he called me far right it was hilarious
but he's he he's 20 he was 26 yeah yeah
i think so
so these 26 year old lefties on youtube
think 35 year old tim poole
who believes in universal healthcare and
social programs is far right
that's good though that means you're the
trojan horse you're controlled
opposition no no it means that in
in in 10 more years when or in even
three to five years these young people
are going to come up and they're going
to see a traditional conservative and
think
nazi and they're going to see moderate
liberal and think
far-right conservative if it if the
train goes goes as it's
as it's headed but we you know society
is not linear things don't happen
we constantly are changing the narrative
and shifting and altering the way things
are happening
well there's one thing to consider and
it's that liberals don't have kids
oh yeah right we're going to out breathe
them i mean this has already happened
this is already happening though right
like i mean
when gren glenn greenwald retweets my
stuff or interacts with anything
immediately he's he's labeled as like a
crypto fascist
and then people will like screenshot
things that i write and be like this is
who
glenn is promoting this like fascist
authoritarian
and stuff and so i mean it's already
happening um
but i think the the anti-trump ads
on you said disney i think it was disney
channel okay anti-trump ads on disney is
like a good day for disney considering
all the other smut that they
right that they run for children and i
think this this kind of gets the issue
of like critical race
theory where i really appreciate
the work christopher ruffo is like a
national treasure
but i think he has shown that
critical race theory goes so much deeper
than anyone
really thought it did uh and and that it
has
already infected every single cultural
and social tissue
that the the task of uh of extirpating
critical race theory is actually much
bigger and much more daunting than i
think
anyone had imagined before rufo came on
and
came on the scene and started showing
people how pervasive this stuff is
so yeah i wanna uh well actually we'll
we'll jump in a second
um conservatives need to start producing
culture
you know i guess i was trying to look
something up and just but we'll pull
that up in a second
if there is something interesting that
we saw with pew research and that is
that
the previous generation is slightly more
conservative
i'm sorry the gen z is a little bit more
conservative than millennials but only a
little bit
and that's probably has a lot to do with
the fact that you said you know
conservatives are out breeding
liberals so i have to i have to imagine
so i want to add this to what i was
saying before about
you know next three to five years you
might see some dramatic changes
it's entirely possible i'm wrong because
in 10 years
the generation alpha or you know
whatever comes after alpha i don't know
alphagen is it is it's alpha gen then
beta gen
yeah alpha j they might be substantially
more conservative
by simply the fact that conservatives
have kids so you look at like you know
bench appear i love it they call him an
incel
he's got like how many kids does the guy
have 12 yeah 12 kids and nine years
old kids no no he's like four kids um
there's more kids than the people that
call him in so
that's true that's true it's right right
so you know actually i could be
completely wrong
you know we could be 10 years out from a
conservative resurgence
for a lot of reasons it could be that
all of this stuff with police all of
this stuff with the military
is freaking out regular people come
august 15th as bannon said we see these
these um
in schools the parents freak out what
their kids are learning
and then 10 years goes by and the
millennials are now
in their mid to late 40s and then the
next generation is actually very woke
but
most of that actually most of the
generation actually is more conservative
simply by
the amount of conservative kids are
growing up so that's that's that's a
very real possibility
this could be a fluke reaction is very
possible
and i as pessimistic and cynical as i am
in the short term
i have to be optimistic about the future
about the long term because i have kids
i've got one who's about a year old and
then i've got another one all the way in
december
and so i have to hold that hope that
that something like this is going to
happen
because the idea of just like settling
on the on the
the notion that the future will be so
much more horrible for my
for my kids it just seems unacceptable
to me so
look at what a aoc and a bunch of these
leftists are saying oh we can't have
kids because of climate change
it's like okay they're not gonna have
kids conservatives
gonna have kids right yeah and then when
when they do i mean
there could be this could be actually
substantial
if you know you look at millennials
today not having kids but mostly the
left ones
a lot of like non-political people have
kids conservatives have kids
lefty liberal type millennials don't
have kids
so what happens in 20 years is this
country going to become a bunch of
suit-wearing young
young republicans well a paranoid mind
might rebut you by saying well this is
why democrats like open borders because
they can
they can import uh new recruits so to
speak
so and and why they're going after
schools right they know they don't have
kids so they've got to take your exactly
right yeah one problem i find with
conservativism by the label i guess
is that i think that we need to kind of
reintroduce or just enforce
some sort of social conservatism in that
like
you know we talk a lot about morality
and like not going flying too far off
but we need some like drastic
legal liberalism i think we need to take
take liberty with our crappy system and
change it
um so conservative politicians
are not getting anything done you know
they've been sitting around just kind of
like
enjoying the status quo and that's a
problem say as much as you need to get
elected and then do nothing
yeah and we need like really to alter
the system the federal reserve's gone
roughshod
um the central electoral agencies the
police department yeah we've got like
all these
local governments i mean yeah you know i
mean yesterday's conversation was like
particularly brutal we were talking
about just uh
do these with with anarcho tyranny keep
coming
coming up i think a narco tyranny is
obviously happening been happening for
some years now
and i think that's the easiest way to
understand that the system probably
already collapsed
like if if you have people who feel like
calling the places pointless
legitimately like not like black lives
matter where they're like oh no i can't
call the cops if so you know
no like people legitimately saying i
know they're not going to come here and
deal with this riot
but then also fearing if the writers
attack your house you will get arrested
the system is completely broken well i
think the the issue with anarcho tyranny
is that
the anarcho part is by design it's a
feature not a bug
and the point of it is is to to kind of
paralyze
the the decent populace uh into feeling
like they can't
do any of the things you just described
they can't defend themselves they
can't have control over what their kids
learn in schools and things like that so
so i guess it seems like the system has
failed but it
might actually be the case that it's
more powerful than ever but on the other
hand
historically when when regimes become
more repressive
and more overt in the methods with which
they coerce people
to behave a certain way and to talk a
certain way and think a certain way
is usually when they're on the verge of
of crumbling
or instigating a kind of reaction uh
so because really effective systems of
control
are impersonal and automatic so when you
have to start actively policing people
like we're seeing now the capitol police
leaving the capitol
things like that or the bite
administration talking about
monitoring text messages things like
that that stuff is
as much as it shows like the power and
boldness of the
established political order it also
tells us that it it's kind of in this
precarious position where it's
this close to maybe over playing its
hand yeah i think about that with tech
censorship too
because we should have a system i think
more that's granular where you can
choose what you see
rather than them choosing what you see
the fact that they're in there deciding
who gets to say what is like
yeah they're powerful but it's also
showing how
the cracks in their system like well you
know they're afraid
you look at big tech and first i'll just
say you're right
the moves were they're making show an
increasing desperation and panic
and then you look at big tech censorship
and i can't figure out for the life of
me what their goal is with big tech
censorship i i mean this honestly
because these are some of the dumbest
they're supposedly some of the smartest
people but boy are they
dumb i mean if you had a sit-down
meeting you could figure out what was
happening in only a few minutes
i said this to jack dorsey on the jordan
experience when i was just like at the
end of the show i'm like i'm getting a
van
and they were like they started laughing
and i'm like y'all think i'm joking but
i was like if you keep doing what you're
doing
with this with this uh hyperpolarization
on twitter
people are going to come to a civil war
of sorrow they're going to go after each
other it's going to be insane so i'm
getting that van ready i'm going to go
bug out
and you know people were messaging me
laughing saying huh it's so funny i'm
like y'all think i'm joking
now now now look where we are with the
police taking a knee with the riots with
kobe everything that's happened since
then has has
been a dramatic escalation it's like i
certainly was not wrong
i didn't give a good timeline but you
look at what these tech companies are
doing
i couldn't figure it out i can sit here
and say here's what they started doing
in 2000
or in 2010 in 2011 2012 and look at each
year the changes they made
twitter free speech wing of the free
speech party you they used that to build
themselves
up create a platform then you look at
the past several years
they make they make moves to make money
they make moves to hyperpolarize what
they are doing
is only making things increasingly worse
so the question is
is twitter trying to stop the
polarization well they're not doing that
so it's still only getting worse and it
has been getting worse
okay then they want the polarization
well
i i i guess if i had to if i had to look
if i looked at what they were doing and
someone said
take a look at this system and the
equation and the map
what is happening i'd say jack dorsey
wants a civil war
mark zuckerberg and susan wojcicki want
people to literally attack each other in
the streets
that's the only thing i can i can
understand from it yeah
so to ian's point i think you're also
seeing this in this shift
toward antitrust action increasingly
conservatives populists
are open to antitrust action i think
part of it is just
a matter of enmity people are angry
right
and to your point jeff bezos
literally booting parlor off the
internet
was probably the stupidest thing he
could have done because what that did
far from killing whatever narrative was
being promoted on parlor that he thought
was problematic i think it was related
to the january 6th thing
instead it just resulted in more people
than ever
especially conservatives who generally i
think would have been opposed to
something like anti-trust like
taking a hammer and smashing amazon are
now all for it
yeah so you're seeing this now there's
no political willpower to do it no no
i there is absolutely an effort to
kind of throw an olive branch to the to
the populists
and say look we're trying we're trying
to do something we're putting together a
raft of legislation
we're trying to take measures to bring
to heal
uh amazon and facebook and twitter and
stuff like that but you're right that
there's this kind of reluctance and
a way to to to do something without
actually doing anything
uh but i think the kind of like the
cat's out of the bag
and it can only escalate i think you're
only going to see this trend toward
demands for anti-trust action increase
at least
from conservatives i think that liberals
are probably
more opposed to it sorry liberals are
more opposed to it because
uh they're in power right now these
institutions these corporations
uh for the most part they're doing what
they want them to do
and so at the same time that you have
conservatives pushing for antitrust
action
you have people who are on the left
saying well the thing that facebook
needs to do is not be broken up but
actually just kick
conservatives off of the platform
completely i think jen sackey said
something recently that
if facebook bans you you should be
banned from all platforms
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you